okay we're in Sweden for Christmas
I guess I'm so excited because we found
a bunch of Swedish snacks that I haven't
had in forever
this I got that oh my god I want to have
one now I when I saw it I just lit up
cuz we eat this doing Christmas they're
so good
oh my god
now you see these for breakfast it's not
good but we have we're just waiting for
our Christmas I'm gonna meet my family
and you guys are coming along for this
long
excuse me while I go hey might see it I
dare you to get that sneaky I suggest a
damn Wow we forgot our luggage at the
airport
that's enough how we managed to do that
I'm so tired we have to go back oh I'm
so stupid I can't completely forgot the
luggage I'm too tired to deal with this
right now
I'm just like here we go again
back again
fell close well well well
[ __ ] sake we're in Stockholm with no
luggage I'm sorry I'm gonna have to go
early tomorrow it's a hotel even open
hello so late good morning I got my
luggage
I'm so happy heck man might say would
have killed him seriously
we get the bag with all the guests going
to meet my parents now I don't know if
you've seen them in a video before but
you will today that's exciting
I'm also getting a tattoo today I
managed to book from an artist I really
like while I was here in Sweden so I'm
really excited for that as well so today
should be a very fun day alright so I'm
here with my family we have a mom
beautiful mother mommy pie hey beautiful
sister funny and daddy hey we're all
having Christmas breakfast and I just
say too much oh and by the way this is
my niece nephew nephew Arnold I'm an
uncle hey so cute
did we look alike not really yeah he's
so cute he looks so scared of me I'm
sorry I know so this is ink you guys
from M if you watch me a long time ago
you'll recognize ink
okay so she's quite the character so
cute and this is Puma oh she loves me
okay so now we're going to get their
tattoo and my my parents are getting one
too all right it's got the sin salon
looking very nice I'm really happy with
her look I'm excited
[Music]
all right get the lines dead
Franco my left right butt cheek fell
asleep it's really weird
all right you can peek now I love it
look at my dad's baby thing that's so
cool
yeah you like it I love it that's
awesome so cool the detail is amazing
I wonder where all that dotting you were
doing was I was like that's cool it
looks way better in person so you like
it now I really like it I don't know if
my dad liked it but I really loved it
I'm so happy with it I just love getting
tattooed like I know a lot of people
have opinions about it but for me it's
such a great experience
I'm always he was really cool it's such
a great experience
I just I'm so thrilled I got to do it
while I'm here I think my my dad will
like it eventually um yeah we're just
going to get some lunch then
it's nice it's nice to be in my home
territory feel good I feel Swedish okay
so let's see mommy pious reaction to the
tattoo you're there it's kind of right
those you can't really see it's a church
it's the suture oh it is connected just
one second mr. buck I got it yeah okay
yeah it's the roof kind of open yeah I
pick it out oh that's what scared that
he was like he did it no it is sheriff
or Miss Kitty's oh it is yeah that was
your chamber yeah yeah I feel the same
should I take my shirt oh you got me
again okay thank you mom thank you yeah
[Music]
it's present time what did you get mercy
America some that say oh we love y'all
sorry just hop in it Oh what is it what
is it I can't wait
this is the worst oh oh it's so cool
[Music]
well this one bit
oh my god it's amazing thank you so much
Oh need in over 60 you shouldn't have
gotten no you don't even know what it is
I know you do and there's nothing yeah
oh I sit from the way ah thank you
is a t-shirt super cool thank you so
much thank you
[Music]
so now we are going to gamla son which
is the old part of stockholm to look at
the Christmas stuff
yay you like Stockholm oh wow so now
we're looking for the Alawis that's like
super narrow I remember going as a kid I
thought it was really cool so I wonder
now if I will still be impressed by this
alleyway all right here it is this is
the alleyway oh that's creepy it's nice
welcome to Peter Pan was down an
alleyway this Mike if I do in albums my
camera hey Pat oh you got to look dead
inside what do I do one-way battle I
can't do it this is cool
it's not it's not like crazy I don't
feel like class four phobic or anything
okay that was a really fun day I gotta
clean this Jesus that's disgusting
mm-hmm okay
it's amazing hey I'm so happy with it
I'm jealous
yeah tomorrow is Christmas Eve in Sweden
we celebrate on the 24th and you Val
film some bits so let's go to that gold
you Merry Christmas as we say in Sweden
see we celebrate Christmas is the 24th
we're getting that we're going to my
sister's house to celebrate I don't know
how much I'll vlog of it but I got doggy
putting on the seatbelt okay thanks dad
you're vlogging I am blogging food you
good you go Joe go Joe go Joe
so this is what my dad makes every
Christmas it's Matt it's potato great
Gretchen what's the call
no there's no way that's what it's
called it's the best the potato gratin
would kill that Moe man okay two points
two four
I'm so excited for all the Swedish food
this is the part of Christmas that
really matter
screw friendship family and kindness
give me the food alright we're going for
a little Christmas walk I didn't really
log anything at all today but it's been
a really nice Christmas I'm so full I'm
so much food it's the best um yeah I'll
just see you tomorrow
riffing this is this [ __ ] date of lock
and go Jill and there's a tree everybody
there's a tree oh my god Oh
oh my god it's snow uh oh yeah hey Marty
got him okay we're leaving now mom bye
bye come on it's trying to get us to get
all the food and I can't eat anything
else
mom stop it's time to start we're
leaving
by do I look tired let's guess what time
it is 8 o'clock it's really nice
Christmas did you enjoy yourself Murcia
she loved it
ah we are back home in Sweden I wanted
to check out my taters oh yeah I'm so
happy with it
uh the tortoise did such a great job
it's the church where I grew up during
summer and my sister actually got
married in the church as well and I
wanted for a long time a tattoo day
that's not necessarily about heritage or
where I'm from it's more about just
commemorating my past life in a way if
that makes any sense um I spent 21 years
in Sweden and then as soon as YouTube
hit it off I just like you know and I
never came back
it's 21 years of my life and I have you
know obviously a lot of great memories
and and I'll always look back on how my
life could be so different and it's an
amazing thing where they were used to
best taking me but I still love where
I'm from and I love my family and I love
Sweden and I'm so glad I did this visit
because it was so nice to meet my family
and and just be Swedish for a while
you're probably watching this a lot
later but if you yeah I hope you had a
great time with your family and friends
during Christmas or whatever you did I
don't care well